hey guys welcome to yet another episode
of congratulations
crazy
[Music]
oh it's a coat that's it it's a coke
um
we're off and running we have a new
episode of congratulations got some
stuff on my notes ate some pasta no i'm
sorry i didn't eat the pasta i ate
chicken and rice and then i ate a
cheese ball a fried cheese ball and my
stomach is a naughty yay i may have to
stop to go number two yay don't want to
start it off gross or else calvin would
say
that's what he does whenever someone
says gross he goes
and it melts my heart
um but that's that's what's up dude
workout's been okay sorry strong i
started to break a heart strong guys i'm
just so good i'm sorry and um things are
good i'm wearing the make friends in the
comments uh pink long sleeve shirts just
ready to kind of peek in a fall you know
what i mean i mean i know it's pinfall
but fall just kind of opened the door a
little bit it opened the door slowly
like you're trying to peek into the room
isn't it it's just opening the door
slowly falls just opening the door
peeking in right now that's what falls
doing
uh it's not wide open it's not with arms
white oppa but it's it's peeking in
and uh and that's what's happening uh
season wise
so uh but we got that merch here crystal
dot com go over there and then we've got
the new life rips colorway and it's
called sandstorm and i is so freaking
sick that i can't even believe it dude
it's so freaking sick it should come
with a thermometer it doesn't though um
but it's yeah it's sandstorm it's
[ __ ] it's that sand color it's the
color of my old g wagon i used to have
and it you know it was inspired by that
dude and the the writing is
is uh it says life rips and it's black
and it's just so killer dude and it's
like just peeking in the door for fall
man
you know when i think of merch when i
think of what i'm designing and how i'm
doing it i think of how it works season
wise and this new merch with the friends
of the comments and the life rips and
all the shits man it's just peeking in
the door at fall that's all it's doing
it's just opening the door and popping
its head in like anyone anyone home
that's what it's doing and it's doing
that to fall that's what it's doing
it's all good i'm healthy and um
so we're having a we're having a good
time over here at the congratulations
another thing let's get this [ __ ] out of
the way dude because we're we're proud
but uh try not to show one fire's
reflection in it but we can show
cooper's reflection in it there's cooper
right there being a good boy laying on
the but the more crystallia channel is
uh is we we got over uh we got i don't
know we have a 150 000 followers on
there but it's been good because we've
been doing those with chris videos and
the clips it's got the clips on it it
used to be called clips for the babies
and we changed it because we want to
broaden our horizon it's all good but
you know how that goes
but we have fun with the jeremy renner's
thing we have fun with it but we're not
going to overdo it not this time we're
not going to overdo it but you know when
i get spicy
you never know what's going to happen
but
uh
anyway so what do we do now what did we
do all week think about what you did
this week think about what you did this
week and the week you had let it all go
just let it all go this is a silly goose
time we're gonna have like i say [ __ ]
npr we're just going to have a good time
maybe you turned off npr because you got
the notification that congratulations is
coming on right and you're just like you
know what i don't want to learn about
[ __ ] air conditioning in the 1950s
i'd rather hear a silly goose time and
that's why you're here and that's why
this is a cult
right that's why this is a cult [ __ ]
we don't say his name but [ __ ] jared we
don't you know we don't we don't ever
say his name here at this
congratulations [ __ ] but [ __ ] jared leto
he was trying to do a cult but we don't
say his name but he is not even in the
discussion dude right
he's not in the discussion
so he can try and do a cult and
everything but it's not that jared leto
can but we don't say his name but it's
just he's not like
he's not like me if you see like a you
know what i mean two cult guys walking
up to each other one's me and one's
jared leto or whoever we don't say his
name we know who's coming out on top
right that's the baby's in full force so
that's what we got going on
um
but yeah i'm a gamer
and that's it i've streamed way too many
times to not be a gamer and i used to
say i was a gamer and a little
insecurity would would peek in you know
a little insecurity would peak in but
now no insecurity peeks in because i'm
i'm a gamer dude i came to 3am last
night
went to bed kristen didn't even hear me
coming to bed and then woke up in the
morning and then had a whole day and
then in
the in the evening i was like i think
i'm going to play red dead redemption 2
again and she goes like this oh really
and i said yup and she said wow i said i
know i'm all backwards man because i
streamed so much last night and she was
like oh um
when did you go to bed and i said three
o'clock and that was not a lie but it
was a little bit after three o'clock it
was like 3 15. but i kind of like you
know what i mean i shaved 15 minutes off
of it and she goes and she says wow and
i said i know but honey i'm a gamer now
and i'm sorry dude
i'm sorry but i'm a gamer so follow us
over on flex avenue we're having a good
time dude i shot a [ __ ] ram you know
what i do dude let me tell you something
about these video games dude first of
all not you know much like other things
i thought
i thought that maybe some this is what
i'm realizing about myself when i'm
trying new things and honestly trying
video games is a new thing for me
so what i'm telling you is it's not
going to be the whole thing that i don't
like like i don't like sports right but
i'm sure that there's a sport out there
that i would like to play i'm very
active you know i'm sorry to break heart
strong guys but i'm very strong and very
active
weightlifting that's kind of a thing i
like i like throwing around a kettlebell
you know what i'm talking about
and um
[Music]
so that's what i like doing
and so there are video games which i
don't like as a whole there are video
games i do like a network dead
redemption 2 and i love that game and i
can do whatever i want
and uh i'm spreading activism in the
game that's what i'm doing i'm an
activist in a red dead redemption 2. and
i did
a stream i didn't realize how much of an
activist i was until i did a stream on
red dead redemption and this guy this
old timer this guy with like one of
those ring around hairs with no hair on
the top but it was long like that i
don't know why some people actually have
that cut still now dude there will be
bald guys that are completely cue bald
and then a ring around hair with and
it's long but what but what are you
doing though right
but what are you doing growing it long
when you don't even have it on top but
what are you doing though right are you
a friar no
because there are no friars anymore
so this guy with one of those long it's
like you know what it's like it's like
your ears are wearing a cape that's what
it looks like right
and so this guy was wearing his you know
his his
he was his ears were wearing a cape and
he had on this [ __ ] vest and a nice
tie you know how everyone used to dress
up before 1960 no matter what no matter
what time period it was
everyone dressed up
everyone [ __ ] dressed up it doesn't
matter what 1920s everyone was wearing
like a suit and [ __ ] 1940s hey what's
going on kid you know like that kind of
[ __ ] and then way back into the [ __ ]
king's time they were all decked out and
[ __ ] or you were a knight right or you
just couldn't afford clothes
but if you had clothes you were dressing
to the [ __ ] nines before 1960 1960
people were like what are we [ __ ]
doing dude
let's roll around in the mud let's wear
hippy [ __ ] let's [ __ ] kiss each other
we don't need to be dressed for that
you know i mean back then you know in
the 40s and 50s people had t-shirts but
they were nerd dwells
so anyway i [ __ ]
i asked this guy it became socially
acceptable to wear a t-shirt ever since
1960 is what i'm saying but anyway so
i'm in red dead redemption 2 and this
guy asked me to go get his pocket watch
he asked me to go get his old gun that's
an antique and he
asked me to go get his ledger now if you
play
red dead redemption 2 you'll understand
what i'm saying but if you don't play it
you don't understand what i'm saying yet
and that's good because you can come
along on the story with me come on dude
i was playing it for the first time just
like you're hearing it for the first
time so this old guy asked me to do the
thing and i went and i found this guy's
pocket watch
i found his old gun which by the way
there were already two thieves in his
house saying hey partner this is this we
already found this house and i said and
i had to [ __ ] risk my life i got the
gun from the guy of course i looted him
i got about [ __ ]
you know a dollar and a half which is
loaded back then and then i found the
ledger i read the ledger
i read the ledger a little bit
and then i stopped it and i was like
what's going on right i was like what's
going on i don't want to have to read
this whole thing and somebody in the
chat says basically he's just not a good
a good guy somebody on the flex avenue
chat says you know what he's not a good
guy just go ahead and return the ledger
so i return the ledger and as i'm i get
to the guy with the [ __ ] skirt around
his ears
right with the cape
like his ears have a cape on it remember
that guy in the beginning of this story
i give him the ledger and my character's
mad at him
he's like hey man i don't know why you
wanted this [ __ ] ledger you shouldn't
be doing this and that and i'm like what
the [ __ ] is going on here my character's
mad but i'm not in this game right
because you know me when i go full force
i go full force when i go do something
it's all in and i realize i'm cheating
myself
and i'm cheating flex avenue on twitch
i'm cheating it
and
it's only we're we're hurting the
experience right
so i say to the chat why is this guy so
mad
and somebody says oh well
you just found out that he
he owned slaves
now you know
what we believe as a cult on
congratulations okay
slavery is not good all right i've said
it before in this podcast and i will say
it again and i will say it until my
heart stops beating okay
slavery is not a good thing to do all
right i've always said that you know
there's a lot of flip-floppers
politicians going to you know joe biden
used to be like oh yeah i think only men
and women should get married we have no
place for gays and now he's all like hey
gay it up i got flags printed
right flip-flopping and flip-flopping
isn't necessarily a bad thing because
you want to grow and evolve as a human
being but one thing that i'm telling you
i will never evolve from
is slavery is not a good thing to do
it doesn't matter how many decades pass
how much time ticks your boy dalia will
always be against slavery okay
so now i'm sitting i'm thinking i got an
audience on flex avenue i'm like how do
i deal with this [ __ ] right
and like yeah he owned slaves and i was
like whoa first of all whoa for rockstar
games for even broaching the subject
whoa i mean i know this game gets bags
there's a part two already and they're
working on part three i mean whoa but
they broached it and even if they did
try to say see if some woke
[ __ ] came after rockstar games
and was like hey you shouldn't be doing
this even though it's part of history
you shouldn't have this in the video
game it teaches the wrong message to
kids whoa they won't stop because bags
they won't stop right because rockstar
games is a corporation what do we know
about corporations they don't give a
[ __ ] about anything except bags
but here i am not the corporation
i'm just a guy behind the [ __ ] remote
control trying to play the game right
and i'm like you know what what's the
right thing to do here because you could
do anything in this game
i mean
i gave
a donation in this game to a lady that
was trying to help homeless and then you
know what i did
she said thanks i took it back
not only did i take it back i took
everything in her box i already took the
donations
all right do i feel bad about that
no but my character might
but what i'm saying is
not doing slavery is a [ __ ] thing
dear to my heart so
a hog tied him
i hogged item somebody in the chat said
he's not worth it let him go and i said
he's he does slavery and we don't stand
for that so i hogtied him
and then i picked him up and i brought
him over to the fire because i thought
it would be funny because i thought oh
how funny would it be if he caught fire
but video games you know video games you
know them right they're not real life
so i just threw him on the fire and for
like 30 seconds he was just on the fire
and i was like see
video games aren't ready
they're not like real life people are
like oh video games are like real life
if they're real life then how come
sometimes when i park my horse it's
standing like that right sometimes when
i park my horse it's standing literally
like that when horses would stand like
that it doesn't look like real life in
red dead redemption it's very beautiful
but please stop saying video games are
like real life
so i'm just sitting waiting looking at
them in the fire and i'm making fun of
them because video games aren't real
like real life and i say to the chat i'm
like look at this dude so [ __ ]
ridiculous and all of a sudden the guy
[ __ ] catches fire
the guy starts burning alive
the old man with the [ __ ] cape around
his ears starts rolling around hog tied
and goes oh my god
and burns alive
and i felt crazy so i [ __ ] took out
my dual wielding pistols and i shot him
in the head so he wouldn't suffer right
yeah i wanted his life to end because he
was all into slavery
but i didn't want him to burn alive so i
shot him in the head
and then when i rolled by on my horse
for the rest of the stream i told
i told them me as crystalia
every time i rolled by a black person in
the game i told them i told them what i
did i said i have a i have a crazy story
for you and i told them exactly what i
did i hugged out the guy and i burned
him alive
so you have a nice day
so don't come to me and tell me that i
don't do activism all right
they tried to crash my stream two times
because they don't want me doing [ __ ]
activism [ __ ] in red dead redemption but
it's all good follow us on flex avenue
anyway dude we have a silly goose time
dude but we also are activists
that activism that i did was way more
than any activism show that cbs ever did
or will ever do that show will never
come out i i guarantee it like that guy
in the [ __ ] burlington coat factories
guy the [ __ ] ass guy and i guarantee it
you know the guy that literally looks
like [ __ ] that guy's literally one of
the most famous people i've ever you you
could ever see if you if the burlington
coat factory guy walked into a cafe is
it burlington coat factory men's
warehouse yes don't even know the name
another guy's face [ __ ] reps
the men's warehouse guy if he were to
walk into a cafe and you were there you
would be like that's the i guarantee it
guy you might call him the burlington
coat factory guy but you'd know the face
dude that guy i swear to god the
burlington wait no it's [ __ ] what is
it menswear has the men's warehouse guy
if there was a fame off in america i
don't know what it's like in [ __ ]
denmark or whatever but if there was a
fame off i [ __ ] you not i mean it
including tom cruise including the rock
including gerard butler including the
guy from [ __ ] home alone who who uh
what's his kid name what's the [ __ ]
who's mcauley mclachlan dude including
those guys okay including everybody all
right if you took the [ __ ] not the
berlin coat factory what's the guy the
[ __ ] men's warehouse guy he would
come in and i [ __ ] you not a hundred and
twelve that's the 112th most famous
person in the world that's how many
times they ran that commercial they
still run it
they still run it and guess what this
shit's out of business but he'll still
pop up on your tv in a different
commercial and be like i guarantee it
remember me from men's warehouse
he's so recognizable that guy
and if you're a [ __ ] indian baby or
if you're a [ __ ] you know uh an arc
an antarctic baby or a [ __ ] you know
where do they not get this
congratulations podcast but you still
stream it from wherever
you might not know this guy but in
america this guy is so [ __ ] famous
he's 112 famous person in the world
okay
uh and 113 honestly is woohoo uh
jean renau so
that's you know i'm just saying that's
how [ __ ] famous the guy is he's like
a little bit more famous than jon renau
but anyway
uh
yeah dude
we've been playing some red dead
redemption and we've been doing a lot of
this stuff uh a lot of the activism in
there i went hunting for one of the
legendary meets this is for the game
guys dude but i went hunting for a ram
and it took me 30 minutes to hunt the
ram i found the ram
i shot the ram really early on i'm gonna
be honest i i shot i thought i had him
like in the first half i [ __ ] thought
i had him you know how they say it and i
shot him and i kept trying to get him i
couldn't shoot him i couldn't get so
frustrated all of a sudden 30 minutes
later i'm looking at the ram the ram
goes like this
and falls and it hits the ground and i'm
like what the [ __ ] chad's laughing at me
i'm like all right what happened and
it's like it bled out it bled out for 30
minutes dude i kept him once pop pop and
then [ __ ] the ram blood out 30
minutes later he just took a nap dude i
put rams to sleep
who am i the chargers
i don't know no the chargers are the
rams maybe i don't even know at sports
really at this point the chiefs whatever
it is every team's got a racist name
whoa
we gotta lay off this [ __ ] button in
all honesty sorry to stop it in between
the [ __ ] sting but um yeah
so what else did i do this week that was
way too long to talk about video games
but i will talk about this thing you
know your boy you know what he is oh
[ __ ] cooper hit the thing we got to
move it back a little bit he
does it look okay it looks okay right
okay cool [ __ ] cooper bad dog cooper
lay down cooper lay down
cooper lay down
let's get him out of the room yet
because he ruined everything cooper
ruined everything
um cooper go go outside all good go
you're beautiful i love you but go
um
what was i saying about the [ __ ] oh
dude you know what kind of guy i am dude
when i do something i'm all in that's
what i was talking about with the
activism [ __ ] you got to be all in in
your life no matter what you're doing
you're playing video games if you're
doing my new chat or if you're doing
some [ __ ] serious save the world [ __ ]
you got to be all in because otherwise
what are you doing dude remember life
rips but life only rips as much as you
make it it's your head space dude
and my head space is absolutely firing
on all cylinders of all and i say
cylinders dude this time because i mean
it
okay
be you [ __ ] 100 life hops in
take that ride
[Music]
hey guys
listen this episode of congratulations
is brought to you by ship station okay
the holidays are coming up soon they're
fast approaching and if you're selling
anything online which a lot of you are
and if you aren't you should be let's
face it because it's a really great
lucrative thing it's time to prepare for
the busiest time of the year figuring
out the best way to do it and how to
ship your orders can be really
frustrating and confusing trust me i
know
shipstation makes it quick and easy and
very convenient all right you can easily
import orders from any sales channel
automate just about any shipping task
and spend less time
sorting through the actual orders of
more time doing what you do best
my merch store is on shopify and ship
station connects right to that
um if you also have a shopify store and
it helps us make sure everything gets to
you dummy fast and dummy organized uh
got a lot of positive responses on that
and shipstation helps us do that so
that's great um it integrates all
selling channels into one simple
dashboard it's very easy to use you can
seamlessly connect
uh
carriers
print shipping labels and get products
out the door fast
over a hundred thousand people
sellers use shipstation in their
businesses okay so
what are you doing not being one of them
uh it's never too early to start
prepping for the holiday rush and it's
already getting late so
just get a head start with shipstation
my listeners can use my offer code
that's my offer code here
congrats
it's offer code is congrats to get a 60
day free trial just in time for the
holidays that's two months of
stress-free holiday shipping for free
just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top and
enter
congrats
ship station make
ship happen
[Music]
so no matter what you do when you do it
all in now that of course
is synonymous a little bit with my
addict i'm an addict right we all know
that i suffer from addiction
i'm in therapy you know i'm in a program
i have a men's group right i'm an addict
but
you know that's real talk but it
permeates it to everything in my life
now what happened
the other night was i turned on netflix
all right now i'm a i'm a hulu i'm going
to be honest with you guys okay i'm on
netflix a lot but i'm a hulu guy
all right
why am i a hulu guy because i started
watching things like lego masters and
some reality stuff and
[Music]
gordon ramsay stuff and he's on about 30
of what hulu has
uh for real i mean gordon ramsay has so
many cooking shows but also he'll just
pop in and like a movie that willarnette
is in and he'll just be like how's it
going get out of the kitchen and will
our net will run out of the kitchen and
be like sorry
but um
he's in it you know like he'll just be
in a [ __ ] what who's that guy the
george the [ __ ] uh who's the guy that
plays the
what's going to be funny
i was going to be jeffrey
who's the [ __ ] guy who got the actor
best actor jeffrey the old old guy and
the [ __ ] pirates of the what
jeffrey rush dude
hell yeah dude he was in the movie
quills
jeffrey rush was in quills acting in
quills and all of a sudden gordon ramsay
was in one of the dungeons and he was
like out of the kitchen
anyway i was i'm a hulu guy is what i'm
saying
you know but i turned on netflix and the
first thing that popped up was and
here's how much my attic permeates into
my regular life
i'm in
dude i'm in bed and i start
a movie that jake gyllenhaal is is in
it's a new movie that came out on
netflix and it's called
the guilty all right now i don't know if
you know much about me and how i feel
about jake gyllenhaal but there's two
things i feel about jake gyllenhaal all
right
he is a fantastic actor no cap that's it
wrap it up that's it
wrap it up right we're done here he's a
great actor that's how good he is you
could say that and just end on it right
that's how good of an actor jake
gyllenhaal jake jill knows a great actor
guys okay let's pack up let's pack up
let's file these papers let's get
everything all done i'll do the
paperwork right
here's another thing about jake
gyllenhaal he's too weirdly buff in
every part he plays okay
right like he'll play a pizza delivery
guy and you're like why is he so [ __ ]
string bean jacked
right
why is he built like a [ __ ] brick house
and he works at a call center
brickshit house why is he built like a
[ __ ] brick [ __ ] house
and he's a [ __ ] pilot you know what i
mean jake gyllenhaal is just all like
i'll be the pilot and you're just like
hey you're a fantastic actor but do kind
of a you don't have to do totally what
christian bale does
you know christian bale will play
[ __ ] uh vice the vice president
dick cheney but he'll just be like oh
you guys know i'm i'm dick cheney right
and while i do this movie there is no
dick cheney that's not me okay so here i
gain [ __ ] 100 pounds and go bald
right you don't have to do what he does
i think that's ridiculous
and that'll only land you to a viral oh
good for you
moment right
remember that moment we know here at
congratulations
but um
so
now we're talking about jake gyllenhaal
and jake gyllenhaal is a fantastic actor
but he's also weirdly string being [ __ ]
uh brickshit how strong no matter what
the [ __ ] he plays right ever since he
played that movie where he played that
boxer where his wife died and eminem did
the soundtrack he's just seriously
string being [ __ ] brick [ __ ] house
buff even when he's playing he'll be in
honestly he'll do like a voice in the
new ice age movie
and and you'll still be like okay but
he's too string being
brick [ __ ] how strong
as this squirrel
right
so weirdly buff fantastic actor
all right so
i turn on this movie the guilty and i'm
in bed with kristen and she's like you
just put something on i put it on
now all of a
sudden we're watching the movie and this
happens so much with my lady man
she'll tell me to turn on something
i'll turn it on
i'll get invested
she'll tell me she doesn't like it
anger rising
okay
but we do therapy so let's quell the
anger
but at this point it's too strong rising
now why is it too strong because jake
gyllenhaal is a fantastic actor he's
drawing me in he's doing cryings when
he's not supposed to be doing cryings
and
he's not crying when you think he would
be crying right like that's how jake
gyllenhaal will be like his he'll watch
his wife get [ __ ] shot up by a bunch
of gangsters and be like
mary mary mary right but then i'll ask
you for a baked potato in one scene and
you'll be like why are his eyes welling
up the guy's unpredictable dude
except for his body his body's
predictable we've learned that so
so
so now i'm watching this movie the
guilty and i'm all in and she's like i
don't like i don't like stuff where like
i don't like stuff for like maybe the
kid the kid dies in it and it seems like
the kid's gonna be dying in it and i'm
just like okay but you told me to turn
it on and i'm invested she says well why
don't you just go into the why don't you
go why don't you go into the you go into
a different room you go into a different
room now
what people on tick tock don't know is i
have more than one tv now what why i say
the people on tick tock is because i
posted a video where i was watching tv
on tik tok and everyone says wow why did
you hang your tv too high above the
fireplace you should hang it lower and
they're saying it like i don't have
another tv that might be lower and more
comfortable to watch now let's not talk
about that because this is about the
movie about jake gyllenhaal but
i do have more than one tv okay so i go
downstairs
to finish the [ __ ] movie
i'm in therapy i quell my anger i say
okay sweetheart good night leave her to
do her crossword puzzle and listen to
murder podcasts and i go down
now yes i am watching the tv that is too
high on tech talk but it's all good it
doesn't matter i was watching it and
it's fine to me all right
so i'm watching the [ __ ] jake
gyllenhaal movie
and it is
12 30 okay half of the hour the movie's
over
so i'm like i guess i'll watch the whole
thing it'll be over at two [ __ ] it
but the movie draws me in
it draws me in really good and i feel
uncomfortable
and i'm not going to spoil the movie
but
it's very kind of sad what happens but
by the end
you're left with some sort of okay
you know that uh that nice american just
the character did what he had to do even
though he was a weird flawed person
right that's pretty much every american
movie no matter what the movie is
it doesn't matter if the guy's an
anti-hero a hero or a [ __ ]
you know whatever else there is
the guy in the american movie
even though he's flawed he kind of ends
up doing usually the right thing right
that's usually what the american movie
is about
the movie ends and i'm like wow
jake gyllenhaal sure can [ __ ] act his
way out of a paperback you could
probably put him down [ __ ]
in you could put cement blocks you could
kill him like lips manliness and dick
tracy and he would still [ __ ] rise to
the surface
by using acting like he could probably
act his way out of a [ __ ] out of
cement blocks is what i'm trying to say
so i'm watching
a movie and it ends and at the end of
the movie
it says
let me just pull it up to make sure
uh it's the right thing here
it says
based on
den
skylage right
now it says based on den
skylage
i'm looking at this word
my first thought is i can't see what it
says
okay my next thought is my heart beats
fast am i dying
because what is this word den skylage
skyldidge right
and i think is it based on a person
is it ben skyldidge
and then i think no cause i got closer
den skyle didge
so i google
ben skeldige and while i'm googling
while i'm typing den skylage i'm
thinking
i have this wrong
because it's not a word and not once
did i think
it was a foreign word
so i googled then skydige and my phone
did the thing where it was like i was
taking so i was like no no back back
back i got to spell it and then no don't
predict it it's [ __ ] dense skylage i
keep looking back back back it's not ben
skyridge it's den skaldich back back
back and i finally hit the [ __ ] x and
then i google it boom
it's a movie from denmark
movies based on a book fine movies tv
series based on a graphic novel fine
movies based on a poem
fine movies based on a story somebody
told you once fine movie based on a
banana fine
but when you base a movie on a movie
that's already successful
you gotta tell me before i watch the
[ __ ] movie
that's unfair
you play dirty that's a dirty game
netflix and i've got a bone to pick with
you
yeah
okay
we've definitely had our differences you
know
i've worked for you you cut me out of
some stuff whatever we won't talk about
it but what i will say
is if i'm gonna be watching a movie
that has an that's about a movie that
already happened
you [ __ ] tell me
hey hold up
there's a different movie that's
actually this movie first
but you didn't do that
so i googled it
and i was all in like i said in the
beginning of this i'm all in dude i'm
all in when i watch a [ __ ] movie
and when i googled it i thought hmm i
wonder if i could see dense skullditch i
wonder if i could see den scaldage right
now
so i looked up where to watch then
scaldage
and guess where you can watch then
hulu
now let's go back to the beginning of
the story
i'm a hulu boy
okay
that's what i am
i've told you that
so when i saw that den skaldich was the
first movie that was the guilty on
netflix only it's on hulu and it was
made by the way not even decades ago
two years ago
i went right to hulu
and i accessed it
because i have netflix and hulu
and i started watching then scaldage and
i have to be honest with you even though
i am all in and my addict this is attic
behavior by the way through and through
even with little things that permeates
like i said
i started watching the movie
and i thought i'm just gonna watch and
see how the guy does it if he doesn't
like jake gyllenhaal or how many of the
lines are different or the same or
whatever
so the movie started and
jake gyllenhaal sure can act his way out
of some cement blocks but this guy
this guy was the guy
this guy was doing everything that
christian bale does but without all of
the weight without all of the pulling
hair out of his head
he was just simply the guy
because i didn't know this guy sure he
was probably very very famous in denmark
but what the [ __ ] do i know but he was
just the guy at the call center
acting
with no string being brickshit house
body
he was just some guy doing the part
and that drew me in
so i watched the whole [ __ ] goddamn
movie
again
i watched it again i watched both
versions of the movie i watched the
first movie the first movie ended found
out about den skylage and then i watched
the second movie and i watched the whole
thing and the movie was exactly the same
the screenplay was the same until the
end the end is different and i'm not
going to spoil it for you guys
but the end
made
the denmark movie better
okay
it's better
it's better the movie from denmark the
danish film is better
is denmark danish i don't know it's
danish but anyway it's a film
then skylage and it's really [ __ ]
good and it means the guilty and the guy
in it is so good and i want to spoil it
i want to tell you why it's a better
movie but it's just very not american
man
the way he [ __ ] comes to his
you know characters fruition or whatever
the [ __ ] is just so very and i don't
know i've never been there but it's very
danish
and i loved it dude
the moral of the story is
don't [ __ ] remake a movie
okay
two years later
and not dude drives also
or also it says screenplay by dude you
just translated it it should literally
just say translated by and then the
credit should be somebody
translated by done math that's what it
should say that's what it should [ __ ]
say dude
now i i get it dude
you know it's like you want the credit
and cool and everyone needs their credit
everyone wants their [ __ ] credit
nowadays right it's so [ __ ] like
everybody's like well if you posted my
meme you better tag me and tell people i
don't give a [ __ ] dude if i made memes
out there take them as a matter of fact
say my old jokes i don't give a [ __ ]
i won't even call you out on it i don't
care i don't care
i don't care man
there was a comedian that did my joke a
[ __ ] uh a friend of mine the other i
i told him i was like yo just so you
know i did that joke and you put it out
there and and he was like oh logan said
something and i was like look i don't
give a [ __ ] man i'm just telling you in
case you want to [ __ ] know
i don't give a [ __ ]
he probably thought about it on his own
too i'm not saying he even stole it but
like dude my point is
just it's never the movie's never going
to be better than the original movie
right because if it's a if if they're
going to remake it that means it's a
success so in effect if it's a success
just you're not going to make it better
that doesn't mean you're not you can't
get bags okay fine but it's you know
netflix wants the content but there's
not even a theater release
so it's not really even making bags
but um i watched the movie i've been
watching a lot of [ __ ] man i don't mean
to make this whole thing a [ __ ]
review but it's like uh whatever dude i
saw i i i saw squid game by the way dude
squid game okay i'll tell you right now
i am not a [ __ ] hater i tell [ __ ] how
it is you know me and i'm no cuda dude
i'm not trying to like like [ __ ] because
of the hype he says this while he's
wearing yeezys yes fine i understand i
like the look of the shoe but still dude
i don't [ __ ] buy the hype
but i turned on squid game because of
the hype because i'm like let's see what
this is all about maybe i could talk
about it on my podcast turned it on
hooked liked it is it as good as
everyone's saying probably not but it is
very good it is good but everyone's
acting like this show
is jesus
and the show in fact does not jesus is
just some show and it is very good some
of the acting's very good they draw you
in it doesn't redo the wheel it's not
like [ __ ] uh breaking bad that shows
great it's not sopranos it's not even
the wire and sometimes in the wire i'm
like yeah no i i guess it is good right
everyone love the wire and i'm sitting
there like yeah yeah
yeah no yeah and i don't really know
so i'm watching the [ __ ] thing and
it's drawing me the [ __ ] and i like
squid game dude i like it a lot i like
the games they play they got to play
games they got to play six games there's
450 people that come into a place uh by
choice and they have to play games to
stay alive and the as the six games go
by people die until there's very few
people left and they got to split the
money all right that's what it's about i
summed it up nicely
that's what it's about and it's good and
i watched it in two two and a half days
okay i was very loser-ish doing this but
i did it and i was happy about it
and i tried to watch it in the [ __ ]
uh voice over shits
because you could do that on the
streaming shits you could turn on audio
and you could be like i'll be like you
know at first they were like
and i'm reading it but i'm like kind of
missing it and [ __ ] and also i can't
text my friends while i'm watching it
because i got to be reading the [ __ ] so
i'm like maybe i'll turn the voices [ __ ]
on but when they do the voice acting
dude why are they it's so bad it's worse
than video games
in video games they'll be like you might
want to talk to the stork
the stork has that information
but dude in in in like subtitled [ __ ] if
you turn the american or the uh the
english or the whatever it's so bad
they'll be like oh watch out i'm coming
through it'll it'll be like a guy with a
stack of papers just like oh watch out
i'm coming through
and then if you turn it off and rewind
it and you just read the subtitles and
you listen to it in korean it's like
oh they're actually acting well
so i turned it on for a little bit then
i turned it back off for a little bit
and i started reading it because these
people are just like whoa
hold on i'm coming through
oh and forget it if there's a kid
if there's like a six-year-old in it
because the [ __ ] actor if even if
it's like a boy a six-year-old boy it
will be like a 40 year old woman that's
like
hi um excuse me you know and you're just
like oh jesus dude
so i'm watching the [ __ ] squid game
and it's great and that's cool good gay
squid game i like it and you know what
i'm a big proponent on
people americans especially seeing [ __ ]
that isn't
uh necessarily american
right
it's a korean series great that's why
i'm plugging den scaldage right now you
gotta see this movie it's great and it's
danish
and it's not american
but boy when i say that watching that
[ __ ] up my netflix algorithm
all of a sudden i'm like
am i in asia
i turned my tv on and i'm like hold up
and i'm like
hold up
am i close to eagle rock
what's going on
hold up
hold up for a second am i am i in la
canada high school again hold up
are we some of the only people that'll
drive an acura integra in 1996 i'm like
hold up
my netflix is koreaned out i'm like hold
up am i am i the only race that still
uses hair gel i'm like hull up
am i wearing am i still wearing polo
ralph lauren i'm like hold up
do i have arnett sunglasses i'm like
hold up
do i have a picture of my girlfriend on
my dashboard in my car or a picture of
me in my car in my wallet i'm like
like hol up
i'm like hold up
i watched one series and the [ __ ]
netflix [ __ ] just
made my home page korean dude
i'm like hold up
they even brought other asian [ __ ] in
there wasn't just korean which shows
that [ __ ] i'm watching another one
i'm realizing it alright let's play all
right let's play the algorithm again
let's play it let's play it netflix i'm
a hula boy but let's play
so i played the [ __ ] and i'm [ __ ]
halfway through one of the first
episodes on this new show and i find out
it's japanese dude and i'm like oh
dude your algorithm's racist
they all look the same huh
how streaming service they all look the
same
and you ask why i'm a [ __ ] activist
on red dead redemption 2.
because there's injustices out there
i can't believe you listen to [ __ ]
npr when we're talking about the
hard-hitting issues here on
congratulations the
podcast we always talk about
hard-hitting issues on the
congratulations podcast
previously on congratulations kings and
queens and [ __ ] presidents alike
everyone's just sat on that toilet just
grumping
just taking a [ __ ] grump
see
anyway dude
we have a good time and it's honestly
not even that hot right now maybe it's
because it's [ __ ] cooler outside i
got the fan going on in the corner here
it's the only room in the house that
doesn't have air conditioning and it's
fine dude
you ever read a danish word and think
that you're having an aneurysm i did it
speaking of red dead redemption i tried
to find the [ __ ] arabian horse
pissing me off dude
it's in the snow and of course it's
white so it's hard to [ __ ] see it and
kristen's all like you're still up and
i'm like i'm looking for the [ __ ]
arabian horse
[Music]
and that's just me [ __ ] without
warming up dude i've been yelling for
the past 45 minutes but right now i'm
just like
[Music]
all right you guys we're doing it we did
honestly dude i just cut because i
wanted to look at misconnections i
didn't even have to cut dude i did not
even have to cut there is a cut there
but i'm telling you we cut out about
[ __ ] nine seconds and all i did was
google miss connections and this was the
first one that i that i got okay home
depot first of all it's called
all right and it says
saw you at home depot in the hardware
section and couldn't help but notice the
impression you were making quote-unquote
south of the border
ah
essay innuendo
shortly after that i went to the john to
let out some of the coffee i had that
morning and
not gonna win rover wait no this is
probably a dude on dude right yeah not
gonna win him over actually dudes don't
give a [ __ ] man hey i'm gonna evacuate
my bowels wanna bj sure that's a dude
those are two dudes
dude hi just threw up all over
everything would you like anal
absolutely
um
uh
i took a urinal next to yours and as i
started to drain my bladder you i mean
this guy's draining a lot huh let that
coffee out and drain my bladder oh he's
not talking about [ __ ] oh i thought
he was talking about [ __ ] because
coffee makes me yeah never mind um you
turned and showed me your tool just say
it
just say it at this point just say it
someone came in and you left i was in
mid-stream so i had to finish up before
i could go i looked for you but you were
gone
if you see this please reply i'd like to
talk and see more c is in caps
we got it
so if you're not him and going to reply
i don't mind oh
a [ __ ] hoebag
a male hoebag
just let me know what area you're in yes
i'm still looking for him do not contact
me with unsolicited services or offers
do it hey
man
just
write this
any dudes around for [ __ ]
this guy led with the hole yes so i saw
you at a home depot and had to drink
coffee what are you saying cause then
he's like by the way even if you're not
this guy
let's get on all fours
hey guy
what does do not contact me with
unsolicited services that's all you want
hey dude
this guy i really want to [ __ ] but also
anyone but make sure
if you're anyone
not to solicit me
hey dude doesn't make any sense
wow man
i love it dude
oh wow
um
i love these ones you used to come over
[Laughter]
like dude what did you never take his
[ __ ] number
it's so easy to find someone in this day
and age when did they used to come over
in 1982
hit that now
hey the guy who's trying to read this
he's dead now
cause just google
man missing his buddy it says
you used to come over to my place and
you would unclog the drain hey guy
just say it
just say he used to pork my anus or suck
me off
you don't have to say unclog the drain
if this was you or you think you'd like
it to be let me
hey
you could just rewrite this to
any guy out there up for [ __ ]
if this was you or you think you'd like
it to be let me know i've missed you so
you've missed
anyone
do not again with the do not contact me
with unsolicited services or offers
hey guy that's all you're doing
hey if you're the guy i'm talking about
great if you're not cool but if you're
not
don't write
dude
the guy's dead now
because it's so easy to keep your
[ __ ]
so great
dude
here's one table manners
redondo beach
huh this is pretty normal for
table manners i i can't believe you
didn't i did not ask you two ladies to
join me for a ring to drink friday night
you both are stunning i hope to see you
and we can have a drink sometime do not
contact me with unsolicited services
oh house house sitting
whoa
oh
house sitting and looking for another
dude to mess around with i'm dressed up
as a sexy latina today always looking
for side work
wow
wait hold on this one looked like it
could be good armenian
armenian and weho guy what's up in weho
and looking for some company me five
eight 170 pounds send pick please
straight to the point
look at these i saw you at the market
downy you were the girl looking at my
package but did not get your number i'm
the tall latino
[Laughter]
oh you did all right wait he sent me
some here we go
miss connections number one
orange guy a tall lady on a turtle walk
ah
that's what it's the [ __ ] title
a tall lady on a
turtle walk
are you sure she was tall or sh
did she just look tall
because she was walking a turtle
should have said hello we have similar
taste in leisure activities and
automobiles
what is a similar
leisure activity
as
walking a turtle
yeah i like to walk my lizard i walk my
polar bear
do not contact me with unsolicited hey
dude how much is this just a guy that
saw a hot chick and they made eye
contact by mistake on her part and he's
like oh that's crazy man i would love to
walk a turtle
i had a buddy like that
he'd always be like yeah man i would
never do this with a chick and then he'd
be like well you know it turns out i
actually really like it just because
some girl [ __ ] liked them that did it
oh my god
the [ __ ] title of this one missing
missing a lady to eat out
scross
sacras
my dad listens to every episode and now
has to hear that
missing a lady to eat out ride offered
from to huntington beach
you come over to me i come over to you
or we can do it in my car single white
guy is here in good shape right offered
from oc to l.a
weird weirdly
made it about the ride you know
[Laughter]
like
like let's not forget yeah i i
definitely like to go downtown but i
also need to go downtown
uh let's not forget i need an actual
ride yes of course
you know i'd like it to be boner
inducing but also
i actually need
or just likes driving people i don't
even know if he's the one
oh no he's offering the ride jesus
christ weirdly about the ride huh
all right
well i guess those are those are good
ones
we brought back uh missed connections
maybe we'll keep going keep keep going
uh next time i know you guys been really
want me to do it at least a lot get a
lot of comments
wow i like this one llama lira and then
is the title and then the subject
lamilira where are you
hey but who are you
it's not a misconnection if you're just
like hey
you know
wow
this is crazy that this is a real thing
that people do
tj maxx cerritos i saw you in line at
t.j.maxx this friday afternoon the one
located by cerritos mall you were the
one you were the girl with the ram
tattoo on the back of your neck i'm the
guy who was wearing a green long sleeve
plaid shirt and car hard cap wow so
descriptive i guess you have to be we
exchanged glasses and i wanted to ask
you for your number but i was
also in a bit of a hurry if you're
interested email me and describe what
you were wearing you never know i might
be the love of your life scrape
hey god bless
oh boy
oh wait
what is this
i was nauseous coming out of titan y'all
watched venom
there were two of you i saw y'all coming
into and out of our respective 8 p.m
movies me titan e
you venom
let there be carnage you said y'all
watched raw just yesterday
doc nero's mind is so astute and poetic
and gnarly do y'all go to the movies a
lot do you want a friend to watch [ __ ]
with i'm new to l.a and just to be clear
i have a boyfriend but i just want some
pals to scream about movies with whoa
this guy's just looking for literal
movie buddies
wow
the world's a crazy thing eh
okay
well that's it maybe
we're done huh
is that good
okay
you guys that's great go to uh the uh
chris talia.com to get this shirt here
that i'm wearing make friends in the
comments and don't forget to make
friends in the comments below this video
you guys uh somebody hear somebody
getting heated in the comments you just
[ __ ] ask them out to lunch dude they
need it
or ask them where they're from say hey
anybody else from huntington beach maybe
i could get a ride down to oc or [ __ ]
downtown l.a and you know what i mean um
but uh you guys are great thank you very
much and we got the new life rip stuff
in the new colorway patreon saw it first
uh
sign up for our patreon patreon.com and
also
um the uh the flex avenue [ __ ] i've been
having a lot of fun on red dead
redemption too so follow me over on flex
avenue on twitch that's the end of the
episode on youtube but if you'd like to
catch the rest of the episode all you
got to do is go over on over on over
onto our patreon uh patreon patreon you
know what i'm trying to say go on over
to our patreon and you can catch the
rest of the episode patreon.comcrystalia
and you get uh all of the you get all of
the rest of the episodes you get
extended bonus episodes and you get a
bonus episode a month and
the segment review mode that i host and
a bunch of other behind-the-scenes stuff
and we do stuff there's a discord watch
along party uh but you guys can do all
that over at patreon.com and if you
don't uh keep on watching on youtube and
we uh we and like and subscribe we
appreciate it thanks guys
[Laughter]
[Music]
congratulations
thank you
[Music]
all right cool hey i'm all over